Nanaka-chan, I know something about it, so I'm not interested in
people like that.  I can't rest calmly There's a lot of
trash It's
Jajange Week Don't let acquaintances say they don't have additives Are
n't you friends ua
?  What's wrong with
me 6
nan
[music]
[applause]
is down collector
[music]
rar
I was a grandson who learned something new, but it's a click
OK OK OK
2 John It's already a nuisance in the neighborhood
Keroro martial arts chasing 2
ranime
none
dare
After all  He can eat outside voodoo That
's right, he knows our guild.
And it's life-threatening Please take
care of me Buzz
[music]
New yeah
I'm getting busy
Increased to experimental bodies
[music]